ratings agency fitch says it's at risk
of default as a series of debt payments
come due russia due to international
sanctions against the country russia
central bank can't access its foreign
reserves of 640 billion dollars the
government says that it wants to make
the payment in rubles but that would not
be accepted on a dollar denominated bond
if russia can't make the full and
correct payment within 30 days the
country would be considered in default
well anna grossman is an associate
professor at loughborough university in
the uk and researches the russian
economy thank you very much for joining
us anna how is russia's economy coping
under the strain of sanctions
the russian economy has been hit
extremely hard by the sanctions of the
most
difficult part right now for the russian
businesses is due to the increased cost
of financing uh due to the uh
devaluation of rubble so the businesses
are looking at different types of
payments such as cryptocurrencies or
gold and at the same time the government
is introducing new legislations new
measures subsidies to facilitate the uh
continuing operations of of russian
businesses in russia and abroad
so for instance
there is a new legislation which might
allow the abundant assets by the western
companies to be temporarily managed by
an external administrator and then sold
at auction to a new buyer there is
another
legislation coming in place to stabilize
the exchange rate of the russian ruble
against the dollar by providing better
liquidity to the russian bank and
decreasing the amount of speculative
transactions so clearly uh russian
government is reacting to these
sanctions um as much as they can well
you say temporarily acquired i think it
sounds much more like expropriation if
we're looking at the end result with the
auctions what what are companies doing
though to adapt themselves to these
sanctions after all things have changed
rapidly in just the past few weeks
so the hardest part as i mentioned is
the increased cost of financing so the
businesses will be looking at different
types of payments such as
cryptocurrencies or gold
the government is also introducing um a
temporary constellation of the custom
tax on critically imported goods for the
next six months so that would facilitate
or diminish some of the increased costs
on imports of critical products
and components such as vegetables and
grain food ingredients pharmaceutical
components textiles some of the metals
construction materials and spare parts
for aircrafts
okay so from the the russian perspective
there has been talk that it will be
absolutely necessary for russia to pivot
its supply chains that have been cut off
in europe to china how realistic do you
think that is
well it is not entirely unrealistic um
since china is already a major trading
partner in russia chinese brands for
example comprised 60 of the russian
smartphone market but the ruble
devaluation and sanctions may be slowing
down the chinese company's abilities to
replace their western counterparts in
russia um as quickly as possible
however russia will be increasing its
trade flows with china and india um and
that includes the construction of new
pipelines to redirect gas from europe to
china which is more of a you know media
term um strategy well i'd like to pick
up on the russian gas aspect because
there has been talk of either one side
or the other turning off the russian gas
taps to europe how serious would that
step be for the russian economy
well that stuff will be extremely
serious because the construction of new
pipelines to redirect gas from europe to
uh eurasia or china is not going to
happen overnight so this is not like
with oil tankers that can be redirected
pretty quickly so russia will be
impacted by you know this decision of um
closing uh russian gas supply towards
europe quite severely in the short term
and how urgent is russia's debt
situation right now as we've heard the
the risk of default um exists so what
would how would you analyze that
well um in in some respect uh those
companies that hold uh russian sovereign
debt have been already adjusting to this
complication in payments with more than
20 funds having frozen
their
portfolios with significant russian
investment while other funds have
written down the value of their russian
investment significantly
so
if russia defaults investors can of
course claim money on their default
insurance but going through insurance
and courts is costly so investors might
be just advised to hold on to their
bonds for now
russian debt default might also trigger
payments on cgs market which is a
derivative product used to protect
against government default
but still because of ongoing sanction it
may be difficult to recover those
payments on sds as well however the
default on russian that is unlikely to
start the global financial crisis like
in the 90s due to the relative limited
exposure to russia by foreign investors
in in this situation okay well whatever
happens there's still plenty more pain
to come for russia by the looks of it
but thank you very much anna grossman
for joining us it was a pleasure to hear
from you
thank you
meanwhile china says the impact of
sanctions on russia will have a limited
effect on its own economy with regards
to facilitating trade with russia after
the country's exit from the swift global
payment system beijing is offering a
workaround using the chinese sips system
although it can only process payments in
yuan the chinese government also
promises support for financial markets
to keep them stable amidst ongoing
crises
well here's what the head of china's
national bureau of statistics had to say
[Music]
in terms of direct impact russia and
ukraine account for a small proportion
of china's import and export trade so
the direct impact is limited
of course due to geopolitical changes
the impact on global commodity prices is
still relatively obvious
and the pressure of domestic imported
inflation may increase
despite these problems we must also see
that we still have many favorable
conditions to ensure domestic energy
supply
well there's plenty to dig into here as
well and we couldn't do it without
fraser howie author of red capitalism
who joins us now thank you very much
fraser we're three weeks into the war
china is not taking any clear sides on
this and they want to show themselves at
least they have uh said that they want
to to depict themselves as a global
power an alternative to the west yet
they're missing in action why is china
not stepping up on either side
i i think because much of that directrix
which the many in the west and many in
europe have fallen for the china it's
you know it's the chinese century uh
frankly it's just been rhetoric and that
when
the stakes could not be higher at the
moment and china has a real opportunity
to step forward and make a difference it
clearly has leverage with vladimir putin
it has a no limits friendship back
um and yet it's trying to manage this
very
undiplomatic neutrality and i think it's
partly because a lot of the
their talk is simply hot here
so there's been lots of talk of russia's
pivot to china is this an opportunity or
is russia's economic weight simply
negligible for china
i think your previous guest said it that
ultimately the the the russian economy
is a very small part of the global
economy
it's a very small customer of chinese
goods and china of course does have a
lot of times for hydrocarbons and
commodities and i think that will
continue i don't you know china is not
going to be thanking russia at all
um and they're going to continue with
those contracts as best they can but you
have to remember as well that the train
the sorry the
the russian economy is effectively
seizing up and that's going to have
knock-on impacts into the chinese
economy as well you know can ultimately
russia buy the oil and the gas and other
minerals while at the same time fighting
the war and having your economy going to
people but it does fit into a modus
operandi for china right because it fits
into china's plan investments in africa
for example the belt and road initiative
it could see russia as at least part of
that at least if its companies can
replace western ones in russia for
example or it could lend to russia do
you see it as a new domain of influence
for china
uh to some extent but i think it's a
very it's a very limited domain and it's
our it's a pretty poor friend to choose
ultimately russia rightly so as a work
has a long history long supply from rich
culture and what they're not simply
going to become a vassal state of the
chinese and roll over and do as the
chinese say certainly while putin is in
power he is clearly a very unstable and
unpredictable leader which means that
that's a lot of problems for china so
china may say hey we've got russia very
much in our economic pocket but at the
same time that will almost certainly
then have a negative impact for china's
react relations with america
with japan with rest of asia with the
rest of europe okay we can talk about
money flows gdp and so on but is there
realistically any benefit to china in
using russia's natural resources as
europe used its oil and gas
um look china needs a lot of commodities
but russia was selling those commodities
anyway so in that sense it's not really
got a much better position than where it
was before it was a big buyer of russian
commodities it will continue to be a
relatively big buyer of them as i said
china has prospered for 30 years in a
stable global political environment and
russia has completely appended that and
frankly china's all at sea
okay one more um
where do you think this goes next fraser
sadly i think this will probably drag on
for some time um
i think it's just too difficult to say i
think though clearly is walking up the
the germans the europeans and even the
americans to the risk of engagement with
russia and mismanagement engagement and
i think it will also then turn on china
as well and say if we don't like
totalitarian russia then why are we so
comfortable with totalitarian china so
in that sense i do see is a realignment
of much of europe with america and is
what we used to call the free world
okay plenty of lessons learned there
also for china by the locus of it fraser
howie thank you very much for your
analysis on that
well as we heard the war in ukraine and
the subsequent sanctions against russia
had sent prices for commodities gas and
oil upwards recently but it's also
driven the prices for other raw
materials in particular nickel has
rocketed
you can find it in coins
stainless steel
electronics
electric car batteries
it's nickel the fifth most abundant
element on earth
and now the protagonist of a
never-before-seen global pricing crisis
ignited by the russian invasion of
ukraine
in 2021 russia was the world's largest
exporter of refined nickel while the eu
and the us haven't targeted the material
with sanctions global buyers frenzied to
look for alternative sources sending
prices through the roof
on february 24th the day of the invasion
nickel reached the already high price of
twenty six thousand dollars per ton in
early march pricing started rising
steadily spiking to one hundred thousand
dollars on march eighth before settling
at eighty thousand dollars per ton
the london metal exchange which sets
global prices for industrial nickel
halted all transactions for the whole
week
with an unprecedented decision it also
cancelled all trades from march 8
capping the price at 48 000
the nickel crisis sent sparks flying
through the whole industry
chinese tycoon xiang wang da who bet on
nickel prices falling now has to find a
way to bail out his company xinshan
holding as it struggles to cover short
positions worth around 8 billion dollars
the pressure on the industry is so high
that even vladimir putin the head of
russian mining giant noah nicole felt
the urge to comment in an interview with
russian broadcaster rbc he warned
against russia responding by seizing
western properties as it would take the
country back to the isolation of a
century ago
the recovery of the russian economy will
depend on the depth of the crisis we
entered the sooner this situation is
resolved and the sooner normal dialogue
with partners resumes the softer the
consequences for our country
astronomy
is another example of how the invasion
of ukraine is playing against russia's
economic interests but it's far from
clear that the increasingly nervous
stance of tycoons like bhutanese could
bring pressure on vladimir putin to end
the war
so it's a very difficult situation with
some difficult questions and now it's
time for you to ask the questions we've
been trawling through the comments
beneath our youtube videos to find out
what our viewers want to know and
ashadosh pandy joins me now to answer
some of those questions ashitosh what's
our global online audience talking about
the most
well daniel it's uh the community is
mainly buzzing with the
issues around
over reliance on russian oil and gas
then how far would china actually go in
supporting russia and there's of course
talk around
coal the return of coal the king coal is
back that's one of the topics that
actually is of great interest to our
audiences all around the world
okay i want to give you a viewer
question here so m greenwich asks will
china start
to aid russia in a significant way and
what would be the economic consequences
of such a move that's from m greenwich
well it looks highly unlikely uh china
wouldn't want to be on the receiving end
of u.s or western sanctions uh we've got
to understand that the the chinese
economy isn't really in the best of
shapes at this point in time is growing
at the slowest space in more than three
decades consumer spending is low the uh
the it sector has been hit hard by the
crackdown by the government then the
real estate sector continues to reel
from high amount of debt so it's really
problematic and then of the kovitz
situation is still raging there and the
zero covet
policy is not helping either so china
really wouldn't want to
inflict more pain by uh overtly
supporting russia here because these are
some of the more the harshest sanctions
that have been imposed against russia
and it would really be painful for not
only the chinese economy but also for
president xi who is uh looking to uh
secure another term this year
okay and another question here from the
account pros and cons how could
successive german governments not see
this coming they know what russia is
like and has been yet still put
themselves in a position to be massively
reliant on one country for their energy
ashitosh what do you have to say what do
you think
well that's a question that we we've
been getting for
quite a bit now i think many people are
i think asking this question especially
when they see that uh this over reliance
means that the european union germany is
actually having to bankroll this war
that uh the russia is waging uh but yes
uh
if i i in my opinion i think uh the
government has been caught off guard
they became too comfortable with this
relationship that they had with russia
it's its decades-old relationship it has
stood the test of time even during the
cold war russia kept
actually uh supplying oil and gas so
clearly they felt comfortable there they
felt that this interdependence on each
other would actually hold this
relationship
steady but that's not the case as they
are now realizing and even before this
war started there were these problems
because russia was trying to hold back
on gas supplies to ensure that uh the
north stream two gas pipeline was
actually uh approved as quickly as
possible but now i think it's going to
change forever because uh there have
been pledges from not only the german
government but also the european union
to reduce their uh reliance on russia
for gas thank you very much for the
ashitosh pandy for answering our viewer
questions
you can find our youtube page
under dw news on youtube.com
so refugees um have been leaving ukraine
of course but where are they actually
going to
to many of uh any one of uh ukraine's
neighbors moldova romania hungary
slovakia or even to belarus and russia
but more than anywhere else they're
heading to poland and it's provided a
warm welcome to weary ukrainians the
polls also share the fear of many of
ukraine's neighbors that they could be
next on putin's list
or dw's marta grazinska reports from in
and around the polish capital
baking free bread for ukrainian refugees
in warsaw
[Music]
staples like bread are so important
and this is something that the bakeries
can provide
fortunately making bread doesn't cost
that much so we can afford to do it
it's a natural response to want to help
at a time like this
everyone around us is helping and we
want to do our part too
help is certainly needed like never
before every day tens of thousands of
refugees from ukraine are arriving in
warsaw and they all need to be provided
for
[Music]
it's a huge task for the city warsaw's
train stations have become makeshift
accommodation for many refugees
[Music]
60 kilometers outside of warsaw in the
town of wahoof we meet a group of
refugees at a hotel for them it's a few
days respite after seeing their lives
turned upside down by war
the pavats hotel is part of the ahi
group that runs hotels all over poland
18 of them have offered to take in a
total of 5 000 refugees for free
[Music]
some families stay with us for four five
or six nights
in the first week and a half we provided
accommodation for 3500 refugees
helping them through those very first
difficult days after fleeing ukraine
[Music]
the company says it's a major
undertaking even for business of its
size volunteers are coming to the hotel
to keep the children entertained
without them and the many other helpers
the hotel wouldn't be able to manage
we can keep going until the end of march
helping everyone we can
but from april onwards we already have a
lot of bookings
we're hoping all these people will have
some kind of long-term accommodation by
then
but the hotel manager is also hoping to
provide long-term help for some refugees
in the form of a job
i've already employed two women from
ukraine
three others are working on a voluntary
basis right now and have expressed
interest in a job
we'll look into that as soon as their
status here has been clarified
all the other hotels in the arco group
are also interested in giving jobs to
the refugees it's a way of helping
long-term rather than just for a month
or two
[Music]
out on the streets the broad public
support for ukraine is evident it's the
same right across poland
even this small hostel in warsaw has
made some rooms available for refugees
[Music]
i couldn't imagine not doing something
to help at a time like this
but it would be too much for me on my
own
my partner has taken the time off work
so that we can focus totally on helping
the help they're providing goes beyond
accommodation and food most of the
refugees will need longer term support
if they're to find their feet here
with the help of our neighbors we've
been able to organize dance classes for
the children for example
for the women that were interested we've
set up job interviews
right now many businesses are willing to
go the extra mile but they'll need help
if this is to continue for weeks or even
months to come